hi my name is nuñez below I'm an
esthetician and today I'll be waxing
when these arms for the first time we
are hairy girls I mean this is stuff
that woman do like I'm willing to give
it a shot I might like the way it feel
the difference between eight-year-old me
who was made fun of for being hearing
and then me today choosing to get my
arms why is that I want to do it for
myself and as a personal experience not
because I'm under any pressure to I
can't wait to like put silky sheets on
my bed and be completely smooth and I
really swim around not that rock there
this is a shoes okay on shoot Rock Paper
Scissors shoot thank you for being here
boys hot
oh no oh wait is this happening yet oh
my hand was on I'm sorry for Kiki
it's fine it's not that bad actually
it's definitely not that bad I know the
wax pellet feels good now all right that
wasn't that bad at all showing me your
hand or again Oh
area my god oh my god you're right
doesn't feel like my arm silky silky
sheets I can't wait for the key sheet
that was crazy
we did it we did it I'm actually really
excited about the look feel like I'm
gonna be more confident wearing tank
tops and like dresses like this I didn't
have that much hair on me but I've never
waxed anything so that was definitely
like a learning experience and I'm so
[ __ ] dead okay Ben I am so ready